uh we were talking about dominic
cummings a few moments ago that trip to
barnard castle much commented upon
canterbury and police were looking into
it let's go back
to our political correspondent rob
powell who's got some news on this rob
yeah i said a statement from durham
police could have been coming imminently
turns out uh it was very imminently they
have released a statement literally in
the last
few minutes uh in which durham
constabulary uh have said
uh that mr cummings in driving um and
locating himself at his father's
premises
he um dublin police does not consider
that by locating himself at his father's
premises that he committed an offence
contrary to regulation six of the health
protection
act so they concluded he hasn't
committed an offence in terms of that
initial journey to durham
but importantly on that trip that he
took to barnard castle
um on the 12th of april where he said he
did that to check his eyesight to check
that he was
okay to drive the durham constabulary
say they've examined the circumstances
surrounding the journey to barnard
castle
including number plate recognition
witness evidence and a review of mr
cummings's press conference
you can see the pictures of that on your
screen now and they've concluded there
might have been a minor breach
of the regulations that would have
warranted police intervention durham
constabulary view this
as minor because there was no apparent
breach
of social distancing now it's quite a
lengthy statement durham constabulary
also said that
had one of their police officers stopped
mr cummings driving to
or from barnard castle the officer would
have spoken to him and having
established the facts likely advised mr
cummings to return to the address
in durham they also say that in line
with their general approach throughout
the pandemic there's no intention to
take retrospective action
in respect of that barnard castle
incident so
in summary they say that there is no
offence committed in terms of travelling
to durham but there was a minor
infringement of that
um in relation to that trip uh that he
uh took
to uh barnard um castle but they don't
intend to take
um any um action now i think we're
getting a
statement through from downing street
now as well that's literally just come
through a number 10 spokesman saying
the police have made clear they are
taking no action against mr cummings
over his self-isolation
and that going to durham did not breach
the regulations the prime minister has
said he believes mr cummings behave
reasonably and legally given
all the circumstances and he regards
this issue
as close so that statement from downing
street pointedly not addressing
uh the fact that durham constabulary say
that mr cummings did commit a minor
infringement of the coronavirus pandemic
guidelines when he went to barnard
castle simply saying that
and acknowledging that durham
constabulary say he didn't break um the
guidelines by going
um to um to durham um in the first place
i think this will um probably
reinvigorate
calls for mr cummings to at the very
least
apologize and for the government to
acknowledge that what
uh mr cummings did while he was in
durham
did go against what the government have
been saying
that everyone else should do as durham
police do make it
pretty clear that it was a minor breach
a breach of the regulations albeit a
minor breach that would have warranted
police intervention now i think there
will be those that say that this means
that because
dominic cummings is one of the people
who helped
write these regulations then he should
be considering his
position seen as he breached those very
rules you look back at previous cases in
terms of
professor neal ferguson carol coldwood
in
in scotland as well they were both
considered breaches that didn't warrant
direct fines or anything from the police
but they both had to
resign so i think there will be calls
for him to consider his position
uh the government though in that number
10 statement seemed to be
i have no intention at all
from this statement anyway of even
acknowledging that the prime minister's
chief adviser
did actually break um the rules so
a lobby briefing is going on as we speak
you imagine that spokesperson will be
being pressed
quite a lot on whether there will be
some sort of apology from dominic
cummings or an acknowledgement that when
the prime minister and other ministers
defended mr cummings and said that he
didn't break the rules actually now the
police have concluded that he has